just a few minutes we're going to be
going back to that room corn hall in
which we're going to have another
program about we're going to bring you
another program from the los angeles
times festival of books on the vietnam
war cultural full app fallout it
includes the authors of these books uh
the sacred willow four generations in
the life of a vietnamese family by dun
van ma mai elliott also this book it's a
novel gods go begging by alfredo villa
also this book by gail morrison which is
called the sky is falling and finally
the author of this book john weiner on
give me give me some truth the john
lennon fbi files again this all a part
of our coverage of the los angeles times
festival of books we now take you back
to corn hall where the panel will begin
in just a moment
good afternoon
i'd like to welcome you all to
the vietnam war cultural fallout session
of the
la times festival of books at ucla
today as you know it was a very special
day it was 25 years ago today that the
war in vietnam came to an end we know
through those photographs of the
helicopters lifting the last americans
out of saigon from the roof of the
embassy in the cia compound
the war in vietnam left 58 000 americans
dead and there are different counts
about the number of indo-chinese deaths
some say 2 million some say 3 million
following the end of the war one million
more vietnamese fled
at today's panel we're going to look at
the cultural fallout of the war
my name is john weiner i teach history
at the university of california irvine
i'm a contributing editor to the nation
magazine america's oldest weekly
and i'm a
volunteer programmer on
kpfk 90.7 fm
[Applause]
uh i have only a tangential relationship
as a writer to vietnam more the cultural
fallout i'm the author of a book called
give me some truth that john lennon fbi
file
john lennon was in the united states in
1972
active in the anti-war movement singing
give peace a chance
in an effort to silence his anti-war
advocacy richard nixon began deportation
proceedings to try to get john lennon
out of the country
and the fbi assembled a file of several
hundred pages as part of their effort to
contribute to deporting john lennon from
the united states
the legal battle 18 years in court suing
the fbi under the freedom of information
act
with the help of the aclu of southern
california that legal battle which went
all the way to the supreme court is the
subject of this book which also
reproduces the 100 most important pages
of the john lennon fbi file that is all
i have to do with the cultural fallout
of the vietnam war
we have three uh wonderfully rich and
varied presentations this afternoon
we will start
today with
my elliott francis fitzgerald said in
the last session in this room for most
people vietnam is a war not a country
this is not the case for my elliot who
was born and raised in vietnam and then
attended georgetown university on
scholarship
she lived in vietnam again from 1963 to
68 when she worked for the rand
corporation
interviewing vietcong prisoners of war
that experience convinced her that the
saigon regime failed to offer a
convincing alternative to communism
she returned to the united states in
1968 now lives in southern california
most books about vietnam have focused on
the american experience of vietnam this
is her book
titled the sacred willow four
generations in the life of a vietnamese
family is different it's a combination
of memoir and family history
it shows the vietnamese as they saw
themselves as the central players in
their own history
because she had members of her family on
both sides of the war her book is
subtler and richer than most
gloria emerson that acclaimed american
war correspondent wrote there is no
other book like this one it is gripping
and beautiful please welcome to the los
angeles times festival of books the
author of the sacred willow my elliott
thank you very much
i would like to talk to you about the
cultural fallout of the war on vietnam
and the vietnamese and let me begin by
telling you about a movie that was made
in post-war vietnam which to me
captures
many of the aspects of the complex
legacy of the vietnam war
the wives reads or kalau tells the story
of a military officer returning to an
area near his home village to search for
the
remains of missing in action
in a bombed out church he encounters the
ghost of a soldier who questioned
the way his life was wasted in a battle
eventually the officer discovers that
the missing in action are buried on a
nearby small hillock but the hill lock
is now covered with tall tangled wide
reeds which would make excavation very
arduous
while he the officer was still haunted
by the war and the shattering impact
that it had on his life
he finds that his neighbors in the
village have put the war behind them and
moved on
so
while the wild reeds
cover the remains the physical the
physical traces of the soldiers the
memories of their sacrifice is being
erased from the memory from the mind the
consciousness
of the people
so then as the movie portrays
the war in vietnam is there and it is
not there there are still many lingering
scars
wounded
walking wounded
missing in action or soldiers
questioning the wasting of their lives
so the sacrifices that were asked of
them and yet people the memories fading
among the general population
the the vietnamese who lived through the
war don't want to talk about it
they would rather focus on working and
making money and improving their lives
taking advantage of the economic
opportunity opportunities offered by the
new market economy for example when i go
back to vietnam and i want to talk to my
relatives as john mentioned i had
relatives on both sides of the war
i wanted to talk to them about their
wartime experience and they were very
reluctant to do so and when they looked
back they remembered the violence of the
war but they also remembered with
nostalgia the sense of purpose the unity
and the sharing that they think are now
missing in vietnamese society as people
as people become more
individualistic more competitive
during the war
the situation was different because
during the war the government which ran
the north and later on took over south
vietnam
kept the population focused on the war
and the sacrifices that were required to
win
through its pervasive control it made
sure that arts and literature
either reinforce the belief that victory
was certain or the determination to see
the war through no dissident voices were
allowed so art was one-sided
one-dimensional
after
hanoi won in 1975
the cultural climate remained static and
did not begin to thaw until 1986 when
the communist government embarked on a
policy of reforms called daimleri or new
life or renovation and loosened its
control
for example under daimy a novelist like
bauning who to me
has written the best novel to come out
of the war
called the sorrow for
baunin could write about the war frankly
describing the terrible psychological
scars that it inflicted on on soldiers
like him and describe the brutality of
the war
things that before would have been
condemned as
you know a painting to darker picture to
pessimistic defeaters
another
very prominent
novelist called zung tu hung
also
talk about the violence of the war the
mental anguish that it unleashed and
also questioned the sacrifice in human
lives to win
other novelists deal with the theme of
alienation of former soldiers coming
home and finding it very hard to fit
into a new society which they view as
corrupt
poets who were veterans of the war
no longer produce just heroic verses in
more introspective voices they talk
about the traumas about the terrors that
they experienced during the war
and in
films that dealt with this period only a
handful
a new perspective on the war and its
aftermath also emerged i talk about the
wide reads another movie called sin loy
or forgive me which was released in 1993
dealt with the gap in perception between
the young generation
and the generation who fought the war
and glorifies its sacrifice
the
younger generation
is getting tired of the talk of heroism
and
selflessness and they condemn the older
generation of romanticizing a bloody
episode of history so as you can see the
people in the art are beginning to
take a much different approach and take
a much more introspective view of the
war more personal view of the war rather
than just portraying the heroic aspects
of it
with
modernization with the market economy
artists are moving away from the war
theme and more toward the theme of
alienation
and disillusionment alienation
with the modernization of vietnam and
disillusionment with ideology
and the corruption
for example
painters are beginning to paint in
different styles and dealing with new
topics
they mainly paint for the tourist market
and they produce what they think the
tourists want which is
nostalgic idyllic illustrative
landscapes or
abstract paintings depicting anguish
now we can say that the art is
commercial but on the other hand they
reflect the emotions that vietnamese now
experience as the new economy changes
the society alienation and
fear
and nostalgia for a simpler time
now among the vietnamese refugees when
they first came here in 1975 they faced
a foreign culture so their reaction was
to try and recreate the culture over
vietnam they knew so the stores began
selling tapes of old songs
sung by singers who had been popular in
saigon
or
works of fiction and non-fiction that
they reproduced from the libraries so it
was a culture frozen in time
then eventually a kind of an exile
culture emerged created by refugees for
other refugees some began to write
memoirs other road fiction
to recapture the past to relate combat
experience to portray the trauma of
re-education camps part of the
motivation was to keep the hatred of
communism alive
and part of the motivation was to
recapture a path that they knew would
soon disappear
in the memory of the vietnamese
community
now as the children of the refugees are
coming of age the second generation
the war theme is receding it's always
it's still there in the background but
it's no longer a dominant theme and the
the children of the refugees are much
more proficient with english much more
at home in american culture and they
want to reach out to a larger audience
beyond the refugee community
mainly deal with the theme of being an
immigrant in america ethnic identity of
feeling suspended between two cultures
of vietnam and america of fitting in
neither or going back to vietnam and
rediscovering themselves
now
so for the vietnamese
refugees and their children as well the
war is there and it is not there
now for me as an individual i don't
dwell on the war
but as an author of course the war is
the dominant theme for me
um
like all writers i'm marked by the
events that have impacted my family and
me
so it is natural that when i write my
book the sacred willow i turned to the
theme of the vietnam war
so
for me as well
the war is there and it is not there
thank you very much thank you
uh i hope we'll have time at the end of
this session for some questions and
comments from the audience and of course
the
books by today's authors will be
available after this session
outside in area c
also i forgot to ask you to turn off
your cell phones and pagers la festival
books rules
next we'll hear from gail morrison who's
the author of sky is falling an oral
history of the cia's evacuation of the
hmong from laos
the hmong as you know were the laotian
people who fought for the cia in a
secret war against the communist forces
in laos in the spring of
1975 just two weeks after the american
defeat in vietnam thousands of hmong
were airlifted out of laos by the cia
first to thailand and eventually to the
united states
gail morrison has a master's degree in
counseling and psychology she's worked
with the indie hmong community in
southern california for more than
20 years she spent the last nine
researching this previously undocumented
story she's also traveled to communist
controlled laos to refugee camps at the
tai lao border to the bars of bangkok
and to hmong communities throughout the
united states in order to write this
book
sky is falling takes its title from the
code word sky which was used as a
designation for the
cia during the secret war in laos
sky is falling as an oral history that
tells the riveting tale of this last
ditch air evacuation from a covert uh
cia air base in laos in may 1975.
gail did more than 200 interviews to
piece together this story from
eyewitness accounts among seasoned hmong
fighters
to american pilots
wives children students she also
interviewed the cia station chief
as well as u.s embassy personnel please
welcome to the l.a times festival of
books the author of sky is falling gail
morrison
thank you john
here's a pop quiz now everybody who
could find laos on a world map right now
raise your hand
i am so impressed i am so impressed
usually people say isn't that in africa
because they're thinking of lagos
so
it's nice to have a knowledgeable
community of listeners
um
[Music]
i have some slides that i'm going to be
showing with my talk today and the first
one can go up now
since the early 1960s there was the
public
i think it's not there yet it is
can we turn out the big lights the
lights
oh captain our captain can we turn off
the stage lights
yes no does anyone know the answer to
this question michael you're in charge
oh
okay c-span can we look at the slides
yes
in the meantime i'll begin thank you
mice will go off and on randomly
since the early 1960s there was the
public military war in vietnam which was
orchestrated by the joint chiefs of
staff in washington dc next door to
vietnam was laos a neutral country whose
neutrality was ignored by both sides
since no american combat troops were
allowed in laos the u.s set up covert
paramilitary operations that were run by
the u.s central intelligence agency
the cia
this secret war in laos went on for 15
years
our story takes place in long chang
and hopefully
okay
i want to blind myself
yeah
okay
if you can hear me here's north vietnam
south vietnam cambodia
laos
is outlined in the yellow and thailand
is next to it
we're going to be talking about long
chang which is up here in northern laos
and we'll be talking about the udorn air
base in northern thailand
our story takes place in long tang a
remote secret american hmong air base
that had been one of the busiest
airfields in southeast asia for the past
15 years
in spite of this the long chang air base
was so classified that it was not marked
on any civilian map
based in long chang the cia had armed
and trained a tribal army of sixty
thousand hmong anti-communist guerrilla
soldiers under the leadership of general
vong pao who was simply called vp
this army was instrumental in keeping
sizable numbers of north vietnamese
troops occupied fighting along the ho
chi minh trail which ran through laos
while american and south vietnamese
soldiers fought the public war in south
vietnam
from 1973 to 75 there was an unstable
peace and an uneasy cease-fire
throughout southeast asia
then in the spring of 75 there was a
major communist push
on april 17th phnom penh falls to
cambodian communists
on april 30th saigon falls to vietnamese
communists
in laos longchang is the last american
military outpost left and it too is in a
communist stranglehold
my book sky is falling is an oral
history that details the story of the
cia's evacuation of the hmong from long
chang
with the limited amount of time that we
have today i'd like to read to you some
excerpts that will give you sense of the
experience of those intense days during
which 2500 among officers and their
families strong allies of the us were
airlifted out of long chang to udorn
thailand
next slide
we didn't practice can you tell
whoa
well it's usually not yellow but
okay
jim shill u.s agency for international
development
what a place long tang is tribal
soldiers dressed in military garb
standing next to traditionally dressed
hmong with thy mercenaries still milling
about
and the americans here are mostly cia
operatives with goofy code names like
hog mr clean and junkyard
the town itself is not much there's one
paved road running through it and 10
shacks on either side with eating shops
food stalls and living quarters for the
multitude of hmong
not more than 100 yards up a hill and
away from the airstrip is a complex of
cement wood and stone buildings which
houses the cia operatives
sky headquarters
until 1974 the look of the place's
military surrounded by concertina gun
emplacements and sand bags
this is
the long tang valley and
that area is the
sky headquarters
in may the laotian coalition government
is steadily being taken over by the lao
communist faction after the communist
victory in vietnam
chuvang general vangpao's son reports
this scene from a high-level meeting
vp and the son of the prime minister
both get in a temper
vp bangs his fist on the table and says
i already resigned from the lawsuit
government now i'm the leader of the
hmong and the prime minister cannot tell
me what to do
both sides get to the point of a big
argument
the prince bangs his fist on the table
to my dad then jerry the cia case
officer bangs on the table of the prince
jerry is very angry too
jerry keeps saying devon powell just
tell them no even if you say yes i still
say no i won't let you go with them
now the prince knows the cia is right
there
even if the general says yes the cia
will say no
now it is clear to everyone that vp will
leave the country with american
assistance
two days later the cia's air evacuation
from longchang to udon thailand begins
on a small scale with only one lao c-47
lieutenant li tang c-47 pilot when the
evacuation starts the people are not a
problem but the things the bags are the
problem
mostly it's the senior colonels who are
too heavy in the bags
on one flight colonel shuiya's wife has
a lot of bags
when we take off that mountain is in
front of us
we are almost airborne but not quite yet
colonel ya's wife says oy
maybe too heavy if it's too heavy we can
throw something out
but by then it's too late
we put it to full throttle if we are not
airborne we all die
oh i can remember her saying if it's too
heavy we can throw something out
we cannot do anything at that time just
stay calm and pray
jim shill u.s agency for international
development
the way the pilots tell it the long tang
airstrip is angled up at about three
degrees
lifting out of there is difficult in any
case with mountains on all sides and
some not too far away from the runway
i asked one american pilot when they had
to commit for a takeoff and his answer
was fairly simple the way he told it
they committed at the beginning of the
strip could not possibly stop and that
was it
in 1973 i had my first blight outbound
long tang on a c-130
the pilots revved up the engines until
the plane was shaking so hard i thought
it would come apart
when we finally cleared the mountains i
began to recover my breath
airplane mechanic
at night when vp goes to bed chu and i
sleep across the stairway to the second
floor so no one can go past us
we are armed to defend ourselves to
protect ourselves in the general
at night i keep thinking about what will
happen if the plane stops evacuating
people i just think about that by myself
i don't talk to chew about that
i don't know what his plans are but in
the back of my mind i think
chew is the general son
whatever happens they will take him but
me
i need a plan
i decide i will have to walk from
longchang to thailand
i take out a map and look at the map and
figure out which direction i want to go
i think about how much rice i have to
pack on my back and the supplies i need
to last all the way to the border
i have a compass map clothes a raincoat
300 rounds of m16 ammo and a pack i keep
around the corner from where chu and i
station ourselves
i prepare and make plans as a safety
measure
we know we cannot surrender if we
surrender to the enemy we will be killed
we are sure of that
next slide
okay that's a c-46
for two days the c-47 continues to fly
among soldiers and their families to
thailand but the situation gets more
tense as communist troops continue to
encircle the long chang valley
now thousands of people wait at the
airport as panic sets in
on may 12th with approval from the white
house itself american planes join the
evacuation effort
captain les strauss american c-46 pilot
al rich and i are the last two captains
in bangkok thailand al and i are sent
from bangkok to udon to stand by
but we don't know what for
and udor and they say tell us how many
people you can carry out of long chang
and we say none
it's not safe to bring a load out of
longchang in a c-46 you fly a cargo in
you come out empty nobody ever carried a
load out of long-chain with a c-46
the book says if you lose an engine
you're not going to make it so we say
none
and they say
you got to do better than that
we scratch our heads and say okay what
can we do
mrs
lee saikao mother of 11 children has
this to say
the american plain airplane comes but it
is too crowded
full like fingers on your hand
people and people are fighting to get in
there three times we try to get on an
airplane that day
no one has eaten our faces are pale and
our lips are all dry
but we don't dare to go home to cook
we are hungry and we are scared
so scared that we may not get onto the
airplane
we just wait there day and night
next slide please
chu vang the general son
by may 13th we lose control so many
people i see a family push a little kid
onto a plane and finally they close the
door
the mother is still on the ground and
that little kid is sent to thailand with
no relatives a lot of people put their
money into boxes and bags and they throw
the bag up into the plane to make sure
their money is already on the plane
before they try to get on
somehow the door closes
and all the money is gone and the people
are still down there people crying
yelling
and of course nobody really knows what
happens to that money
captain les straus c-46 pilot
there are so many people five or six
thousand waiting for planes at any one
time absolutely mobs and mobs of people
pushing and shoving even pushing other
people off the ladder
we pilots are afraid they are going to
mob the airplane to the point where we
are all going to be stuck here forever
and nobody is going to get out
then we'll have to evacuate by foot
and the last slide
this is wednesday may 14th
mrs
the last day in longchang i do not eat
or sleep for one day and one night i
don't have my bag with me anymore
now we don't carry anything we go early
early to the airport and there are a lot
of people out there people so close
together
even if you pour a bowl of water over
people's heads it won't drip down to the
ground
we make a line waiting to go to the
airplane about 6 a.m the big airplane
comes in and there is a hmong lady in
line behind me
she says it's not your turn wait wait
wait
i wear a big overcoat and she holds onto
my sleeve
she wants to keep me there
i think about it and i don't want to get
lost i say
forget it i pull off my overcoat and
leave my sleeve in her hand
i let it go and i run to the plane i
don't carry anything just my body and
the clothes i wear on my body
we just take our lives and forget
everything else
on may 14 communist tanks and north
vietnamese troops are well within
striking distance of the long chang
airport
before noon the evacuation comes to an
abrupt halt
what not yet
just a moment
while the evening news in america had
given extensive coverage to the chaotic
evacuation of 65 000 vietnamese to
american ships in the south china sea
the cia's evacuation of thousands of
hmong people to american bases in
thailand was never reported
although it was a sprott with human
drama and politics as was the evacuation
of saigon
like all cia operations in laos it
simply
never happened
my book sky is falling says otherwise
thank you
[Applause]
alfredo veya was born in arizona and
worked as a migrant farm worker as a
child and a young man he served in
vietnam and after his just discharged he
worked at a series of jobs
ranging from truck driver to carnival
mechanic as he put himself through law
school now he's a practicing criminal
defense attorney in san francisco he's
also the author of three novels
the most recent is god's go begging it
draws on his experience as a soldier in
vietnam
to portray both the experience of war
and the way the battles still rage in
the nightmares and memories of his
protagonist
as he confronts the social and racial
injustice of contemporary america feya's
novel is notable for the way it draws on
a myriad of cultural and literary
traditions to evoke the special terrors
of vietnam
he in particular deploys the magical
realism of gabrielle garcia marquez in
his visceral accounts of the battlefield
the los angeles times reviewer wrote the
greatest pleasure for a book reviewer is
to announce the appearance of a
wonderful novel
please welcome to the los angeles times
festival of books the author of god's go
begging alfredo veya
is this thing on
i have a friend here named earl who went
to law school with me and earl is the
only one in the audience who knows that
i took that i've spent the last 30
minutes cramming
these two ladies have typewritten
things over here
i got you know
it's just like law school
i i i went to berkeley for nine years i
i actually attended for three
i think i set the world's record for it
well earl you were pretty damn close
for non-attendance
i would start with an aside first
i had the pleasure of meeting studs
turkle
in chicago on his radio show
and i went to see this guy and he came
out and he's a little tiny guy
sort of arthritic and he's over 80 years
old
and we talked about my first book and i
was amazed because he quoted entire
pages from memory
and he would say well that's not what
you said in 119.
you know and if you write things you
know you depend on people's
forgetfulness
but what an amazing mind
but on the same show was michael jordan
and
he asked me a question that studs asked
me a question because you know what how
much michael jordan has paid
and i said no studs i don't and he says
he gets 300
000
school teacher salaries a year
i said stud you're not going to stay in
the air very long
and he says i'm getting out of the
business
america he said let me tell you
something
we live in the united states of amnesia
and he did get out of the business
and we do live there
when i was 17
when i was 17 i lived in berkeley which
was which is a perfect
metaphor for this war
because i was surrounded by you know bob
dylan mario
savio joan baez we're all singing
anti-war things the streets were filled
with tear gas and anti-war marchers and
there i was my little mexican ass
i'd lied about my age so they drafted me
when i was 16.
because i needed a work permit a social
security card and driver's license so
there i am you know i'm 16 i get drafted
and i'm already mouthing all the
anti-war stuff
all of it
you know i can't kill i can't morally
kill anyone i can't do this i can't do
that and in my soul
i wanted to know what war was
that's why i wrote god's go begging is
because i didn't ever read a vietnam
book and there's some very good ones out
there
phil caputo and tim o'brien
michael hare
but none of them no one ever talked
about that
why is it that kids like me wanted to go
one of course because we had no
information
ignorance
is a prerequisite to the infantry
think about now what the word infantry
means it's from french i mean it means
it means where the children go
and that's what they did in the crusades
the first ones to get killed with
everybody under 12.
there's a rather bestial but it's hardly
any better north vietnamese soldiers
sometimes coming at us didn't have any
pubic hair
they were so incredibly young the ones
who were dying there
but there i was mouthing anti-war
slogans at the same time in my heart i
wanted to go to vietnam i wanted to i
wanted the sexual license the sexual
prowess it's promised boys and still is
on television
the few the proud the whatever
the guy with the sword slaying the
dragon the women watching that's that's
precisely what it's about it's the only
time in your life
that you can be drafted is when you're
17 and 18 when you're 20 or 21 you want
to get married you got some money you
got a job you're in college you don't
want to do that kind of garbage
and when you're 30
forget it
and when you're 40 what are you what are
you kidding
you want to draft me
when you're 50
no way no way you want your airstream
but when you're 17
you want the dragon
and you get him
and he's far more than you ever imagined
far far more
but that wasn't the problem with the
vietnam war
i mean there were always wars
the reason this one was different is
because it coexisted with the civil
rights movement
i put some of the i put some things in
my book one of them was the fact in the
american american division you had to
speak spanish
because everybody was was either mexican
from mexico they gave you your
citizenship
if you joined the infantry then that's a
good trade
a lot of african americans a lot of a
lot of poor white kids from
from los angeles
but when martin luther king was killed
on april 8
1968 we weren't told
i think some of you know this
because the american
general staff
and the american government thought that
all these brown and black and poor white
troops would sit down
if they were told so we learned about
four days later from radio hanoi
the same thing happened with with robert
kennedy's death
we weren't told about that either
we were told by radio hanoi four days
after robert kennedy's death
so it's not simply a war with the
vietnamese it was a war with our own
country
they didn't trust us they wanted us to
go out there and kill someone for them
but they didn't trust us
there's something very unique about that
if you think about it
what happened back home was
the anti-war movement
and the civil rights movement began to
meld together that very uneasy coalition
you even had you even had uh people like
malcolm x and and and martin luther king
speaking out against the war that
incredible speech by martin luther king
why i oppose the vietnam war he was
castigated by members of the naacp
for turning his attention away from the
civil rights movement to make that
speech
there were other people on the left who
couldn't decide
which one to join
and the effect the impact of that the
the
the upheaval and the uproar that
happened in america
on those two fronts was like a patient
having a heart operation and an
operation on his brain at the same time
he was completely and totally euthanized
like j offered proof rock
when he woke up he didn't know which one
of those injuries was causing him the
most pain
he couldn't centralize any any given
injury because both of them were so
incredibly massive
and what happened is that
the intelligentsia and the progressives
in america
won
that battle
to stop the war
and to
stop all the racial strife in the
southern states but only by a split
decision
and they've never had enough energy to
raise their heads since
and as a result we're now living in a
place
where
the level of public discourse has
dropped to a menial a menial level
to the point where rush limbaugh is an
intellectual
to the point where george w bush is an
intellectual
to the point where we know that any
person who holds themselves out to be an
intellectual
cannot be elected to high office and we
know that's true
people who run for office here dumb
themselves down on purpose
that's admittedly happened with with
bill clinton
despite his his
aberrations
he's a very bright man
we don't want that
i was in texas when george w bush was
asked who the leader of israel was and
didn't know
and on television people say well you
know something i feel even more close to
him than i did before you know
oh good really
really
is that how you choose brain surgeons
now
it was bad enough it's always been a
problem in our country
because we don't love our own dissidents
and we don't love our own protesters
we love those guys staying and standing
in front of tanks in tiananmen square
i heard
somebody on abc televisions talk about
july 4th
and that person said
that patriots
and protesters alike
were celebrating
this holiday
implying of course obviously
the protesters are not patriots
we don't believe now in what's in what's
known as the loyal opposition
just look at the way the two parties are
acting toward each other
anything that happens when the other
party condemns it for even though they
will do it and even worse
we don't have a loyal opposition we
don't embrace our own dissidents our own
protesters our own differences because
we've grown because the vietnam war i
think and the civil rights movement
stunned us out of it
it wearied us
and another thing that bothered me about
that was
most people
tired of the expense of that war and
they tired of the expense in terms of
human life american human life
i almost i heard nothing when i came
back from vietnam about the number of
people being lost on the other side
and if you need more enlightenment on
that issue just think about what
happened in in kuwait
but we went in there for a ramco
so that so that we could drive suvs
and we know and no one
some people say up to 300 000 died on
the other side it's never been an issue
how many lives versus how many gallons
of gas we can use today it's never been
an issue i think the the cultural impact
of vietnam on our culture
has been the fact that the
intelligentsia
has dissipated disappeared put its tail
between its legs and gone somewhere i
don't know where it is
it's been left to writers
and there's not many of those
what i would have loved to have seen
i think and i think it's a beautiful
thing even though frustrating
with something like the truth and
reconciliation trials
in south africa to have something like
that here where no one is prosecuted no
one is castigated no one's put in in
prison everyone steps forward and tells
the truth
we need it we've always needed to to do
that with our american canon because
it's so rife with with mythology
mythology about race mythology about
where culture comes from mythology about
where music and art comes from i'm sorry
but it doesn't come from britain
truth and reconciliation about vietnam
to tell us who we are so it isn't just a
matter of of recoiling from that savage
injury but coming back
with understanding and empathy and
compassion
about who we are
did you know i mean you know about the
killing fields in cambodia did you know
we paid for it
our money
why why wasn't anybody ever told that
why aren't we embarrassed by that
you know that they arrested pinochet
because he claims he killed 150 000
chileans you know we paid for him
why aren't we told that
you know when i was in vietnam
they had they i remember doing a huge
helicopter airlift
using brand new rockets apache gunships
hitting paper targets
so that
so that
gun buyers from iraq
iran
and every central and south america tin
pot banana republic
could sit there in stands that were
erected for them and watched this
machinery so they could buy it
we did that i spent three days doing
that
do you know who we are
it would be good because i have a lot of
faith in us
and i think that i think that if we do
know who we are we won't let things like
that happen again and we can do it
consciously
and lucidly
and not not just
knee-jerk reaction away from the grief
of war
we need to know our what our history is
and stop being the united states of
amnesia thank you thank you very much
but we now have
we have some time for questions and
comments from the audience we have a
microphone here if you have a comment or
question please line up at the
microphone a few basic ground rules
please no speeches
uh ask your comment uh
as briefly and as efficiently as you can
and if it's directed to a specific
person on the panel let us know who yes
sir
um at one point uh in the second
speaker's presentation
she said that the south vietnamese
soldiers as they went back to their
hometown after the war
were very uh
frustrated by the corruption that they
they met and i don't doubt that that's
so but isn't it also true that the
society that existed before the war
also had corruption as well as a great
deal of oppression
and uh
if i remember
what i read somewhere along my years as
an activist that uh
in china
the peasants had to pay up to 50 of what
they produced to the landlords which was
one of the great driving forces of the
chinese revolution and i believe i heard
that the vietnamese peasants had to pay
up to 60 percent of what they produced
to their landlords
is that your understanding you're
directing the question to me yes yes
first of all yes um the the reason uh
the
the main reason why the vietnamese on
the other side i mean the north
vietnamese and the vietcong fought so
hard was first of all because they had a
great feeling of nationalism they wanted
to get rid of foreigners
like the americans who've been coming
and telling the vietnamese what to do
the second motivation was that yes the
south vietnamese society was very
corrupt and
that's why the
communists had such a strong appeal
among the population because they
held up a vision of a just a better
society a just society a society of
equality and
a non-corrupt society so
these soldiers fought with these ideals
in mind and they never questioned the
just the chess cause
but after the war now they see that with
the new economy
the
official corruption is very
widespread
they see that
people have become too materialistic too
selfish
so those they feel that the ideals that
they fought for uh have disappeared um
and these are this this is the view of
the novelist that i were i was talking
about um so
it's it's that the the vision they
fought for
didn't come about but they never doubted
that vision
could we have the next question please
my question is um how is globalization
has it been
has globalization and vietnam being been
a positive or a negative thing
you know in a lot of places there's
cheap labor
structuralization privatization you know
lack of social programs because that's
the requirement that globalization makes
and there's been pollution as well as
all kinds of environmental
problems
along with globalization has this kind
of thing affected
vietnam or the culture of vietnam
yes globalization has been both a
blessing and a bane for vietnam
it's
improved the lives of the vietnamese
tremendously but at the same time the
economic benefits have not been
distributed equally and this is a
sore point among many vietnamese that
some people are getting rich and while
others are getting a lot poorer
and yes there are problems with
pollution
environmental degradation
indiscriminate exploitation of natural
resources
you know like
vietnam's lost 25 percent of its force
um
so there's a lot of other social
problems prostitution hiv infection
so
there are benefits but there are also
disadvantages so you're right if the
picture is not black and white it's very
gray
i guess my question is directed toward
alfredo veya
and
i too spent two years of combat in
vietnam and i also can relate to you
because i attended the university of
california berkeley thereafter
and i
suffered tremendous guilt when i was
going to that university and i was just
wondering if you possibly since you had
a combat background
uh experienced that too and there's
another part i just want to um i was
part of my unit as part of the
vietnamization process over there
and uh there's a direct correlation i
just know if you knew about that that
between the uh movement that was going
on the united states and the viet cong
was they just seemed to be related i was
wondering if you
knew that was going on too thank you
about feeling guilt is this thing
working it's not working i'll turn it up
i don't know but
yeah i think you know i did have
generalized i still do
have a huge generalized feeling of guilt
and anger
um
i have lots of anger
no because that's
as you well know it's excruciating pain
to go through that every day be afraid
you're gonna die every day this is
horrible and to do it to someone else in
order for it not to happen to you
it's not fun
you're just something you endure over
and over again
now there's
there is no balancing act in the
universe
that was not fair for a lot of people
um
a correlation between between the peace
movement and and what was happening in
north vietnam well there probably was
but you know i didn't i'd never
felt like
the north vietnamese i only i think when
i lost really close friends
i felt hatred
and i felt i wanted vengeance but i
never really felt like i was facing the
enemy i was facing me more
than anything else it looked like me you
know dark hair
that i have a chapter in my book about
meeting someone who kept saying i look
you look just like me
i had more problems about about you know
why i had allowed myself to be placed
there
in that place and then become
you know that
bestial human
that i was
i still i it still
bothers me that i know this secret about
us
how cruel we can be
i can't ever really
really be happy
you know
i know it's just a very thin veneer
keeping us from it you know and i and i
want to make the veneer thicker
thank you yeah yeah our first day wanted
to say to mr villa that you're
um what you thought was your possibly
unfortunate habit of cramming brought
with it a tremendous amount of passion
which i greatly appreciate it um
and uh my question is um
i got through law school too somehow i
don't yeah
yeah
um my question is um
although i could myself list many
reasons but i wanted to ask you of
course um
[Music]
why do you think that those of us and
and all of us who realize the absurd
nature of the injustice and and and
going on in this country that exist now
and existed as soon as the war ended
have put our tails between our legs and
why
um
that's that's my question
well you know a lot of it's been very
conscious
uh
especially on the on the part of the
politicians
to make for the idea of liberalism
became a very ugly word it means you
know spending money for no reason
uh
now it's a really good reason to spend
money for
more weapons and star wars things like
that for some reason we were happier
with that than we are with the idea that
some poor woman is getting money for
nothing
i don't know i think we i think it cost
us a lot it cost this country a lot that
emotional upheaval
and i i think there's there was a a
generation maybe two that simply doesn't
want to go through it unfortunately it
also means that anyone who stands up and
delivers a lecture that
that
has any level of profundity is probably
going to be ignored
we have
we've had a
right wing sort of political
fundamentalist backlash
watch this next election i pray to god
oh please don't let him win
i'd like to ask you a question mr villa
and
i'm one of those veterans that fought in
a war that's been totally forgotten
in fact my brother and cousin was with
macarthur's 24th
and went up to the yalu river only to be
driven back to
busan
my question i want to ask you about and
maybe you can explain i was visiting my
brother
last week in sacramento
and he's still a chance
trying to get rid of those demons that
he suffered
and still suffers
question i wanted to ask is there any
connection between the korean
conflict and the
uh vietnam vietnamese war
it seems to me that there must be
something connecting the two
but i never had a chance to find out
maybe you could comment well i'll tell
you one thing that one thing that
connected them
is that there were thousands of
african-american ncos
in vietnam that had learned their craft
in the korean war
because at that time in the early 50s
this was one of the best places a black
man to go for employment
so my first sergeant the first one i had
when i first got there dongha i put him
in this in my book
it was an amazing influence
on me but there were hundreds of korean
war
african-american ncos
and they still they brought the taste of
the korean war with them and the
frustration
that we couldn't have a set piece battle
in vietnam the way they had in korea
but as for your brother
uh
you know there's unless you have been
there
and you see them coming
and they don't look like you
and they're dressed in a different
uniform and what's going to happen next
is going to be indescribably brutal
and most of you are not going to be
alive when it's over
unless you've experienced that there's
no way else to understand it
or even tell another human being
how it is
or even ever get rid of it there's no
experience i like it it's
it's the worst thing that can happen and
it and if you are in the infantry it
happens over and over it's imprinted in
your brain
if you're in an airplane that almost
crashes they send you psychologists you
know
but a year and a half in korea vietnam
they send you nothing
so i mean your brother's demons are real
and
you know i've been i've been trying a
long time to get rid of my own
i don't know that they ever go away
i mr b i agree with your analysis i was
really touched by your comparison with
the truth and reconciliation
uh processes that has gone on in south
africa
and
i my question is really for for both you
and and my elliott is because it seems
to me that that came about because of an
extraordinary moral leadership
both from the president and from bishop
tutu
and i'm wondering was it our trauma that
disallowed us here in the united states
to ever come to that place had we killed
our minister
who could have done that for us i don't
know but i'm i'm wondering what you what
you think and i'm also wondering if
there's been
any kind of a depth of dialogue
between the north and south and vietnam
about what they've gone through if
there's been any
any any uh raising of the
of the level of dialogue there
well
in vietnam unfortunately the the winning
side
has been
has adopted an attitude of
triumphalism if you will
and it's it's the victor victor's
mentality and so it has not allowed
those who lost the war
those who were on the losing side
to voice their feelings um
the
so there's there's none of that process
and
the um
the reason is that the the government
who is now in vietnam the one who won
the war
is still feeling a little bit uneasy
about latent opposition among the south
vietnamese so it doesn't want to
you know evoke any of that
of those events
of the past so the history
is being looked at from only one side in
vietnam and it is only outside of
vietnam that people are able to
look back
from both sides
i hope i'm not the only one and that
there will be more people like me who
try to see the origins of the war and
the complexities of the war from
different perspectives not just one side
or the other
[Applause]
maybe one what about one minute left off
right now
you know i had a chance in boston to
talk to north vietnamese troops and two
of them had actually been in the same
battle with me
and it was really really interesting it
was
i mean i it's amazing i really felt no
animosity for these people
but i think i think south africa was i
really thought south africa was way
behind us
because it had this absolute apartheid
totally an enunciated apartheid but they
were way ahead of us i mean they got an
african president in you know a couple
of years but he spent 27 years thinking
about what he's going to do
and when he came out he came out he came
out uh with with a measured
compassionate response to that
and uh i think you're right i don't
think we have anybody to do that now
well i'm sorry our time is up we
apologize to the people who didn't get
to ask their questions
thanks to our panelists today and thanks
to all of you for coming
area c is the place where our authors
will be signing their books
that was great so now they're going to
escort us to area c
hi
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
okay
um
thank you
you can see the events book tv covered
live today from the los angeles times
festival of books later at 12 30 a.m
eastern 9 30 pacific
join book tv the first sunday of every